this video is brought to you by udemy so
recently I've been using chat GPT a lot
I've used this to help me come up with
new video ideas I've used it to help me
troubleshoot errors in my code and even
started to use it as a tool to learn AWS
which quite frankly has been a complete
Game Changer in today's video I'll be
walking you through some of the best
ways you can use chat gbt to learn AWS
Cloud I used to think that all you had
to do was type in how to learn cloud or
teach me AWS but honestly charging PT is
a lot more powerful than you think so
make sure you watch until the end of
this video because I'm going to be
sharing with you some prompts you can
copy and paste directly into chat gbt to
learn AWS much faster if you're new here
my name is Lucy I'm an ex AWS Solutions
architect and I've been learning and
using AWS Cloud for the past two and a
half years so make sure you subscribe to
the channel because I make these types
of tech videos every single week okay so
here's what we're going to be covering
in today's video first we'll use chat
GPT to help us design a custom study
roadmap then we're going to ask Chachi
PT to act as a tutor and help us with
any problems we Face along the way and
as a bonus I'll be showing you how to
use chat GPT to build AWS Cloud projects
because as I've said on this channel
over and over again the best way to
learn AWS is by getting Hands-On and
actually building a project let's begin
open up chatgpt and let's just start by
typing in hello the first thing we want
to do is ask charging PT to create a
study plan for us and this is the exact
prompt to type in act as my career coach
and ask me five questions to understand
my study goals once I tell you my goals
in the next message
provide me a study roadmap for learning
AWS I'd encourage you to properly answer
these five questions but for this video
I'm just going to tell chat GPT that I'm
someone looking to land a job in the
cloud and want to get AWS certified okay
so here's what Chad gbt is suggesting to
me but of course based on your own
responses the roadmap you get might be
different they want me to start off with
the AWS Cloud practitioner exam and then
choose a specialization learn the
relevant services and then you know do
some Hands-On exercises however despite
charging PT being really good at giving
you advice on what to do it does have a
few limitations firstly Chachi PT is not
always accurate a common saying for this
is cha GPT sometimes hallucinates facts
and figures that may not be true for
example thinking that a kilo of water is
heavier than a kilo of air even though
both weigh exactly a kilo secondly
Chachi PT's cut off period for its
knowledge is September 2021. this means
that if an AWS certification exam was
updated or new products were released
charging PT would not be able to tell
you that and so with those limitations
even though chat GPT is a great learning
tool it won't be able to teach you
everything which is why I want to show
you how you can use chat GPT alongside
video courses in order to learn from
some of the best instructors out there
and also just make sure everything
you're learning is up to date if we take
a look at the first step of this study
plan chai GPT recommends beginning with
the AWS certified Cloud practitioner
exam and that's exactly how I started my
Cloud Learning Journey as you can see
here I bought this udemy course Top by
stevara Marek back in August 2020 to
help me study for the cloud practitioner
exam I really liked Stefan's course
because of how well he was able to
explain Cloud Concepts there was around
15 hours of video content in this course
and it taught me everything I needed to
know to pass the exam I also ended up
buying his Solutions Arctic associate
course his developer associate course
and also his sysops course in fact udemy
courses have played a huge role in
helping me learn aw us which is why I'm
so glad that also today's video sponsor
if you aren't familiar with udemy
they're an online learning platform with
over 200 000 courses and 57 million
students they've pretty much become one
of the go-to places for learning AWS
cloud and they have some of the best
instructors out there if you're
interested in checking out udemy I'll
put links in the video description to a
list of my top recommended AWS Cloud
courses they offer huge discounts from
time to time so make sure you take a
look at the links below to see if
there's a course that might be
interesting for you now when I was
learning AWS Cloud one of the biggest
challenges I faced was struggling to
understand how AWS Services fit in
together like sure I could watch a video
to understand what ec2 is and watch
another one to understand RDS but I
wanted to know how these Services
actually link together and help
businesses solve real life problems this
is where you could ask Chachi PT to
access your tutor and explain any
questions you may have but even better
what if you could ask charging PT to act
as a Solutions architect or a cloud
engineer so here I'm going to type in
act as a Solutions architect and give me
a real life scenario where ec2
connecting to RDS will be useful
well you can see here that it's already
starting to provide an example of where
ec2 and RDS can be used together to host
a web application so an ec2 instance
will be used to run the application and
RDS will be used as the database backend
and you can see that the answer is quite
detailed where they even consider a
scenario where an application needs to
perform some complex queries that
require a lot of processing power or
memory you could also ask follow-up
questions like when would you choose RDS
over another database option such as
dynamodb
and then you can see that Chachi BT
provides some specific scenarios where
RDS is a better choice compared to
dynamodb I think what's really great
about asking Church upt these questions
is that it really helps what you learn
through video courses come to life and
it also encourages you to be more
Curious which as a result helps new
information stay in your brain for
longer of course don't forget that chat
GPT can also be used for simple
questions as well like what is AWS
Lambda or explain Auto scaling to me but
in general it's better to ask more
specific questions so that child GPT can
generate stronger responses another
challenge I faced was pulling out my
hair every time I got stuck on a
Hands-On tutorial a lot of these video
courses will come with Hands-On Labs
where they encourage you to follow along
but the problem for me was sometimes I
would make small errors and the whole
tutorial just would stop working for
example if I forgot to rename something
on an Amazon S3 bucket policy I will get
an error instead of digging through
documentation and trying to troubleshoot
shoot and figure out what's wrong I can
simply put this code into Chachi PT to
see if I could identify a potential
solution okay let's put this S3 backup
policy into chat GPT and let it know
that an error came up
and straight away chai GPT was able to
tell what the error was you can see here
that your bucket name was not replaced
by the name of the actual bucket which
caused the error so yes instead of
having to read through long pages of
documentation try using chat gbt when
you run into errors with Hands-On
tutorials now speaking of hands-on
experience I want to show you something
very important which is how you can use
chatgpt to build AWS Cloud projects
Cloud projects are not only imported
from a learning perspective but they can
also be helpful for your career when
applying to companies hiring managers
and recruiters want to see that you have
actual hands-on experience even if it's
just through a personal project here are
three ways you can use chat GPT to build
AWS Cloud projects the first one is by
using chat GPT to come up with the
project idea I have a video on my
channel called the best AWS projects for
beginners but in the comments a lot of
people wanted to know what other
projects they can build this is where
chat GPT comes in and here are the exact
prompts I'd recommend what are the best
beginner uh level AWS projects I can
build that will take less than two hours
you can see the first one static website
hosting uh second one serverless
function these two actually were two of
my recommended ones in that video uh but
you can see that they provided a few
more suggestions and a little summary on
what to build but the thing is if you're
already familiar with let's say IAM and
ec2 you might want to ask Chachi BT to
provide you projects on specific
services that you actually want to
improve in so you can ask a follow-up
like you know what about projects
focused on let's say Lambda and amplify
and then it suggests the few that are
focused on those two services
so by asking these types of questions
you'll be able to get charge EBT to
suggest projects that are not only
beginner friendly but also tailored
towards the skills and services you want
to improve on another prompt you could
enter is after building the project how
should I add it on my resume
I get asked this question a lot and I
usually just recommend adding a project
section to your resume and then briefly
explain what you built but you can see
here that Chad GPT wants you to add all
of this information onto your resume
this could be useful for your portfolio
instead of your resume but for your
resume I recommend just writing one or
two lines describing what you built and
to get that one sentence you could ask
give me a sentence to put on my resume
after completing a static website
application project
and straight away chai gbt knows what
you're asking for and you know they give
you an entire sentence that not only
talks about what you built but also the
services you use and what skills you
were able to develop the second way to
use chat GPT to build AWS Cloud projects
is by asking it to give you an exact
step-by-step tutorial on what to build
so once you've decided on a project to
build here's what you can enter provide
me with detailed step by step
instructions on how to build this AWS
project and then you can type in the
project you'd like to build so hosting a
static WordPress website on Amazon ec2
and there you go it pretty much provides
you with each step from start to finish
however what I've noticed is that even
though we're asking chat GPT to provide
detailed steps sometimes it just doesn't
provide enough guidance in that case
just make sure you always ask follow-up
questions so you can see on this step it
says connect to the ec2 instance via SSH
but let's say you don't know how to do
that so you can ask how exactly do I do
this and you can see that it provides
you with further details I've actually
built an AWS project recently with the
help of chat GPT and I'll put a link to
it if you'd like to check it out the
final way to use chatgpt for building
AWS projects is by asking it to
troubleshoot and identify errors if
you've been learning cloud and writing
code you've probably come across Visual
Studio code instead of just copy and
pasting code into chat GPT you can
actually download a chat GPT extension
into Visual Studio code to make changes
directly in the code editor and this is
great if you want to have oil work in
one place without having to switch
between different tabs anyways that's
all the time we have for today I tried
to make the video as concise as possible
so please give this video a like if you
found it helpful and if you've been
already using charge ubt to learn new
things I'd love for you to share your
thoughts in the comments below alright
bye for now